of the page
and now joining us on book tv is
northwestern university professor of law
deborah turkheimer
professor turkheimer you've written a
book called flawed conviction shaken
baby syndrome and the inertia of justice
what is shaken baby syndrome
shaken baby syndrome is a medical
diagnosis
with
extreme legal consequences i've called
it actually a medical diagnosis of
murder
that's because
the diagnosis itself
was thought to prove every element of
the crime of murder or child abuse where
the child lived
and so despite the fact that it emanates
from doctors it it really is a legal
issue and i write the book
from the perspective of the criminal
justice system so you don't see shaken
baby syndrome as necessarily a medical
issue
is it a legitimate
issue medically
it's an interesting question
it really is about diagnosing child
abuse it really is about
finding a
cause in abuse finding a perpetrator as
opposed to any treatment that we tend to
think of as associated with a diagnosis
it's a constellation of symptoms that
that doctors
have said and sometimes continue to say
can prove that a baby was abused and can
prove who abused the baby
when was it first used a as a medical
term and as a legal term well we we see
it in the medical literature going back
to the early 70s
and in the united states it it first
came up on appeal in a criminal case in
the early 80s
it really exploded in the 1990s
why it's uh you know it's probably a
combination of factors um the rise of
child abuse as a specialty within the
field of pediatrics
um you know greater attention to the the
issue of child abuse and and rightly so
um
and
training on the part of prosecutors it
really sort of became disseminated as an
idea in the prosecutorial community
and took hold as i say in the in the 90s
what's been the legal effect of shaken
baby syndrome
caregivers
sometimes parents but but often very
often caregivers
have been sent to to jail and more often
to prison for
lengthy periods of time on the basis of
this diagnosis and that's what we see in
the criminal justice system
in family court we see the removal of
children from those suspected of shaking
babies
you tell the case study of jennifer del
prep
who is she and what happened to her
jennifer
del priet i think is how she pronounces
her name was a
caregiver in illinois
she was caring for a young baby she
herself
was a parent of of two children and had
raised these children on her own
she was accused of shaking this baby in
a case that i
described in the book is paradigmatic of
this diagnosis and the legal consequence
meaning that it's representative of the
kinds of facts that we see when we look
across this category of shaken baby
syndrome
and we look to see how the legal system
treated this diagnosis
she ended up being convicted on the
basis of the three neurological symptoms
that define this uh this diagnosis
she proclaimed her innocence throughout
the proceedings
and she was sentenced to decades in
prison
where her case takes a twist
is is in the past few years when the
diagnosis has come under attack jennifer
del priet was able to convince a federal
court judge here in chicago
that she was very likely innocent of the
charges against her
and she was released from prison pending
the the resolution of her case she still
has outstanding legal claims that need
to be resolved
but she convinced a judge that that she
probably wasn't guilty of these charges
and she should at the very least not be
incarcerated while she continues to
fight
some of her constitutional claims so she
is currently released she is and is she
working at all is she allowed to be
around children i don't i don't believe
that she is i believe a condition of her
release is that that she cannot cannot
work with children
she has now grown children of her own
her children were
more young in the teenage years when she
was sent to prison and they've since
grown up
in your book flawed convictions you
describe jennifer del priet
what's what was her background besides
just being a caregiver
she was a room mom she was active in her
church and active around taking care of
children in that church
she was very involved in her children's
lives and and those of her children's
friends as i understand it
her home was a gathering place for for
kids
and and and i should say never she never
had any
trouble um she was never
accused of doing anything hurtful to a
child or or having a temper um and you
know this is based on the evidence that
was admitted at her trial and going
based on the the witnesses that
testified for and against her at trial
deborah turkheimer what's the medical
evidence
of a shaken baby that's been used the
the classic evidence is is the so-called
triad of symptoms and i'll tell you what
those are
the the first is subdural hematoma which
is bleeding beneath the outside the
outer most membrane layer of the brain
retinal hemorrhage which is bleeding
beneath the back of the eye or in the
back of the eye and cerebral edema which
is swelling and so those three symptoms
the triad
again were thought to prove
shaking
violent shaking by the caregiver last
with the baby when the baby was lucid
so the legal community or some in the
legal community have challenged this
what else could have happened to a baby
if that baby has that triad of symptoms
so doctors now recognize that a number
of
causes can actually bring about this
triad of symptoms
sometimes doctors refer to these causes
as
mimics of abuse because you cannot
distinguish
you cannot distinguish them from the the
classic triad of symptoms that we're
talking about
so there are natural causes of the triad
metabolic disorders
autoimmune disorders
bleeding disorders
a child can have a stroke a child can
have a seizure and this can bring about
those three symptoms that
were once thought to conclusively prove
abuse
in your research
how many people do you think are
probably imprisoned
wrongly because of shaken babysitters
it's such a hard question to answer
because for for for so many years for
decades
no one was really keeping track of this
as a phenomenon that should be watched
and so it's only recently that the madel
justice project here at northwestern has
has started to
to collect data on a national basis and
they've posted this online they've
collected
upwards of 3000 cases i believe of
shaken baby syndrome
over the past decades now certainly not
all of those cases have resulted in a
criminal conviction
but you know we can assume based on
their data based on appellate reported
appellate cases hundreds and hundreds
what is the madill justice project the
madele justice project
is is a project out of the journalism
school here at northwestern
and shaken baby syndrome is only one of
a number of projects that that they
undertake
with a view toward improving the
integrity of our justice system how did
you get involved with
shaken babysitting
i am a former prosecutor i worked in the
manhattan district attorney's office
after graduating from law school
i handled domestic violence and other
kinds of cases but also child abuse
cases
and so i was trained on this what i've
called paradigm
this this triad of symptoms and its
significance
i
you learned from my doctors my expert
witnesses what this was supposed to mean
then i left the the da's office to
become a law professor and frankly
didn't think about shaken baby syndrome
much if at all
until i read
a case that came out of the appeals
court in wisconsin in early 2008 a case
called audrey edmonds
this was another caregiver
who
who was convicted based on this triad of
symptoms
and she had her conviction
vacated by an appeals court in wisconsin
very concerned about the change in the
scientific consensus around this
diagnosis very concerned that
now that we know more about this triad
of symptoms
audrey edmonds
was was
someone who very likely also did nothing
to this this child that she was alleged
to have shaken
i
wondered you know about whether this was
right this reasoning was right i was
concerned because i knew based on my
training as a prosecutor that so many
cases were
factually indistinguishable
from the facts of audrey edmonds that
the same triad of symptoms that
convicted her convicted so many others
and so if this court was right that the
science had shifted
and that there were so many unknowns now
such that audrey edmonds needed to have
her conviction overturned
i
wondered about how the criminal justice
system would adapt
and and respond to the other convictions
very much like hers and so that's what
drew me into the research i wanted to
figure out whether
this shift in scientific thinking really
had occurred
and if so what the implications for
criminal justice would be
are there legitimate cases of shaken
baby
it depends on who you ask there are
those particularly in the biomechanical
community who would say
that
someone cannot shake a baby and bring
about only the triad of symptoms that
you would see other
other signs like
neck or spine involvement you would see
bruises
and then there are those who say
maybe you can and maybe it's a real
diagnosis but we just simply can't feel
confident about diagnosing it based on
these three symptoms alone
um no one denies that that children
babies are abused and that
abusers should be held accountable i
should add that there are certainly
cases where
a prosecution goes forward based on
medical corroboration beyond this triad
of symptoms that i'm talking about the
cases that i write about in my book
are are triad only cases
and you're saying that there are
thousands of those triad only well the
the
database that's online now that madeil
has posted
doesn't break those diagnoses down into
triad only as opposed to triad plus as
we might think of them so i don't know
that there are thousands but i but i do
know that there are many hundreds so why
do so many of these cases these sbs
cases
end with guilty pleas
well the evidence against these
defendants
was was seen as overwhelming
the prosecution was able to present
expert after expert who would
testify with certainty that this triad
of symptoms meant abuse and abuse by the
defendant on trial
and until very recently there wasn't a
whole lot that the defense could say in
response it wasn't until recently that
the defense was able to find experts who
could challenge that you know that
viewpoint it wasn't until recently that
we knew about these alternative causes
of the triad and so with that
overwhelming evidence against even
innocent defendants
i i think would be
enticed by some kind of a deal
that allowed a plea of guilty
with a much lesser sentence than the
sentence that those defendants would
face if they were convicted after trial
so some of the cases i write about
involve a very steep sentencing
disparity
if the sentence after trial would be up
to life
um 30 years 40 years
the deal offered by the prosecutor in
some of these cases was time served so
plead guilty and get out you know get
out of jail now and it's
not simply in the shaken baby context
that i think we ought to have some
concerns about those kinds of police
we talked earlier with uh here at
northwestern with professor robert burns
and we talked about the plea the plea
bargaining are prosecutors feel pressure
to offer plea bargains to get this case
in
off the books
well absolutely i mean prosecutors feel
that pressure defense attorneys feel
that pressure judges feel that pressure
it
it it really is sort of
um the
the way that the criminal justice system
as it's now constituted keeps keeps
moving keeps running keeps working
without those pleas
there would be a drain on the system
requiring resources that you know to
date we we just haven't invested in our
system
so in some jurisdictions up to 95
percent of cases are resolved in
guilty pleas
and and that
the effects of that are felt throughout
the system northwestern university
professor of law deborah turkheimer
thanks for being on book tv
and this is book tv on cspan2 television
for serious readers here's our prime
time lineup for tonight beginning at